- Just as long as it tastes
like cheese (giggles),
that's all that I care about.
(upbeat music)
- Hello hello hello.
We are back at it again.
Another fast-food restaurant
has a new menu item.
Can you guess what it is?
Queso dip from Chipotle
which I'm kind of excited about actually.
I feel like Chipotle's queso
dip should probably be good.
I'm very excited to get it.
I'm gonna try it, I'm gonna
bring it back to the office
and see how my coworkers like it.
Let's do it. I'm excited.
- I'm a big Chipotle fan I would say.
- I grew up with Qdoba,
so a little biased.
- People for birthday's and Christmas
give me Chipotle gift cards.
- I don't eat at Chipotle
that much actually.
- I'm a Chipotle advocate, activist,
philanthropist, and I
used to work at Chipotle.
I love Chipotle.
- I feel like queso and
chips is like the go-to app
at Mexican restaurants.
- I'm pretty exited to try it
because I know some other restaurants
that have pretty good queso like Moe's
and other Tex-Mex places.
- I feel like queso is
more of a you're at home,
hanging with your friends
and like you have chips
with salsa and also queso.
- I think as long as it's warm,
it's good by me.
- I don't care what it is, I
just wanna try it (chuckles).
- I just like cheese.
- It is orange! That's
not what I was expecting.
- Looks like we have yellow
queso here, not white.
- Yeah I see like some little
chili fixin's in there, maybe.
- It smells pretty spicy.
- Got some spice in the smell.
- I can smell.
- A little bit of colors,
some sazon in there maybe?
- To me it smells kinda
like enchilada sauce.
- I am scraping off all the chunks
so I will say that my
review is chunk-less.
- We should just do a little,
little mix first,
- Ooo see,
- break up that oil/fat layer.
- interesting consistency.
- Wow.
- I'm just gonna get like a big'ol glob.
- That's spicy.
- There's a lot of flavor.
There's some citrus, there's some spice.
- If you get the medium salsa at Chipotle,
then you can handle
the spice of the queso.
- It's like the consistency of applesauce.
- That being said, I
am continuing to eat it
in front of your face.
- I feel like this also gives
me like classic nacho vibes.
- Putting it on a
burrito, like this on like
in like my, my bowl,
- Yeah.
- my burrito bowl.
- On your entree is a win,
definitely.
- Oh absolutely.
- If I were drunk and go into Chipotle
and just wanted some cheesy goodness,
I would still get this.
It passes my queso
bar.
- Chipotle still rules.
- Oh yeah.
We'll finish the chips.
- Yeah, we'll take the chips.
- For sure.
- Okay so that's the scoop.
Chipotle now has queso.
They finally gave the
people what they want.
Overall, people really liked the queso.
Some people thought it
was a little too spicy
or that it had a weird consistency,
but the general consensus was that people
would want to include the queso
in their meal at Chipotle.
If you've been to New York
and you've tried the Chipotle queso
or if you'd like to try
the new Chipotle queso,
let us know in the comments below
and that's about it!
I'll just be sitting here on this couch
until the next fast-food restaurant
releases something new.